hey guys it's justine and today i'm
really excited because this video is
gonna be really fun i have been wearing
this for the past
four five months this is the aura ring
so a huge thank you to orang for
sponsoring this video and partnering
with me on this i wanted to make sure
that this was something that i
absolutely loved before even talking
about or sharing any of my thoughts with
you guys and honestly it has been so
incredible and i'm so upset with myself
that i did not get one sooner because i
could have had years and years of sleep
data at my fingertips but instead i now
have a little over four months of data
and what's great though is this could
not have come at a more perfect time
because this is the new gen 3 aura ring
looks pretty cool right yeah well here's
the thing this isn't just a ring it's
actually a pretty high-tech sleep
tracking device with 24 7 heart rate
monitoring period prediction possible
illness detection activity tracking
blood oxygen sensing with seven precise
research-grade temperature sensors all
inside this tiny little ring that
connects to an app that will give you
very specific data about your rest
recovery and how to improve your sleep
quality over
time if i could give you a pill and this
pill would improve your memory and your
skin quality would help you live longer
assist with muscle repair fight off
illness and decrease blood pressure
would you take it um yeah i would but
here's the good and bad news there is no
magic pill but what there is is sleep
and most of us don't get enough of it
and what many people don't realize is
just how important sleep is now of
course we've all heard that you should
make sure that you're getting eight
hours of rest tonight but what does that
actually mean and how do i make sure
that i'm getting enough sleep am i
getting the right kind of sleep what if
i can't fall asleep oh hold on a second
i did sleep for eight hours but i woke
up even more exhausted these are all
questions that i've had and i know that
many of you guys may have also had them
as well so for the past few months i
have been wearing this ring every single
day this is the aura ring and it has
honestly changed my relationship with
sleep now you don't need this ring to
start making changes that can help
improve your sleep but what this ring
has done for me has actually made me see
the data of each night that i've slept
my total time of sleep my sleep
efficiency my restfulness how long i was
in each sleep stage and even what my
skin temperature was it also will then
give me daily suggestions of actionable
items of things that i can do to improve
my sleep this is the new gen 3 aura ring
which has a lot of huge improvements
over the previous one it has seven new
temperature sensors which are constantly
monitoring your body for even the
smallest change in skin temperature this
will let you detect early signs of
illness also period prediction and it'll
assist with determining your quality of
sleep it also now has 24 7 heart rate
and blood oxygen monitoring to give you
a complete look at how your body is
responding to sleep stress and recovery
all of this allows for the app to notice
these subtle changes and alert you that
there might be a chance that you're
getting sick and to take it easy some
users have actually written in and
shared their stories that they spotted
their cover 19 symptoms with aura first
now it's not going to pop up and say hey
you have coven oh justine you've got the
flu but being able to detect those
subtle changes in your skin temperature
can alert you to take some action like
okay maybe i should go get a kova test
or try to plan in a little extra rest
this week just in case you're coming
down with something the aura ring team
has also been working with researchers
at uscf to see how the ring signals can
be used for kova 19 tools most people
don't even know what their baseline
normal is and this takes a lot of the
guesswork out of it this is a sleep
tracking ring but i feel like it's
become so much more
[Music]
so over the past few years i have pushed
myself in training most times i think
i've ended up over training because i
thought that's what i needed to do to
get better it wasn't until a few
injuries later that i actually started
prioritizing rest i had to heal so that
i can continue to perform not only in
all of my activities but just in daily
life even though this was unfortunately
something that i kind of had to figure
out on my own by trial and error injury
physical exhaustion and even making
myself so sick to the point that i had
to take days off because i was so
exhausted but now i'm so much more aware
of my recovery with the aura readiness
score that this has been so incredibly
accurate to how i've been feeling and it
lets me plan out when my best days are
to fully focus on being more active or
when it's just time to take it easy now
these past few months for me i haven't
been able to do as much fitness as i'd
like due to a ton of work it is tech
season and with travel and then i had a
knee injury so being able to take
advantage of the days that i'm fully
rested and recover to focus on being
more active those are the days that i
try to make fitness a priority
so this also has automatic activity
detection which is actually pretty
accurate now it might not always be able
to tell exactly what activity you're
doing but it will pop up with this
little detection notice and you can go
in and choose exactly what that activity
is this ring works so well with other
fitness devices like the apple watch or
fitbit anything that allows you to pull
in the health kit data you can
automatically have that be imported into
the aura ring app and with this gen 3
version i feel like this actually could
be a standalone ring to track your
fitness but i really still do love
having the added benefits of the apple
watch when i'm tracking my runs or my
strength training and also just being
able to listen to music on the go and
having my messages automatically right
here on my wrist i love all of that but
it's great because all of that data is
nicely imported right here for you into
the aura ring app now charging this ring
is super simple it comes with this
little charging dock that you just drop
it onto but the battery life on this
lasts about a week and it does charge
super quick i just toss it on the
charger anytime i feel like i need a
little ring break or a few times a week
when i get in the shower so if you guys
are interested in checking these rings
out i do have an auraring.com ijustine
page where you can go and check that out
to get all of the information about this
ring and you can also buy one what's
kind of cool is when you do order one of
these they send you a sizing kit that
looks just like this it'll give you
instructions to give you a proper fit
you can choose the ring color and your
size selection on their website they've
got gold black matte black and silver
colors i'm a huge fan of gold jewelry
and that's pretty much all i ever wear
so obviously i picked the gold ring one
of the new things in the gen 3 ring is
period prediction women's health is so
often overlooked and it drives me crazy
because this is such an amazing tool not
only for tracking periods it can also be
useful if you want to develop a better
understanding of your menstrual cycle
those subtle changes in your body when
you stray from your normal means
something's up whether it's good whether
it's bad it's honestly so fascinating
reading stories of how this ring has
helped so many people in so many various
aspects of their life there are times
that i'm unfortunately unable to wear
this and it makes me so sad like when
i'm doing jiu jitsu for example i will
wear it for warm up or when we're doing
some drills and then i'll take it off
when i'm actually rolling so i don't
accidentally hurt my partner what's
great is i am able to go in after class
and tag that i was doing martial arts
and it'll add it into my activity for
the day i did put in a very subtle maybe
not so subtle request to the aura ring
ceo harpreet rai to add a jiu jitsu tag
please and from the whole uh jiu jitsu
community now that i think about we have
a partnership with the ufc actually now
that you think about it i think they'd
be super happy if we did that so thanks
for calling it out for the community
fingers crossed for that new activity
speaking of which my sister and i got a
chance to chat with harpreet all about
orange his journey leading the company
into gen 3 and he even gave us some
sleep tips that can help all of us start
forming better habits when it comes to
sleep i have been such a horrible
sleeper for probably the past 10 years
but now with the ring i'm like actually
starting to analyze and like understand
i'm like oh okay like maybe there is
something like i need to have like a
lifestyle change it's interesting right
we sort of take sleep for granted all of
our heads sort of hit that pillow and we
sort of just pass out we we're actually
unconscious right we don't remember it
we take it for granted and some of us
just think oh no we're a poor sleeper
but but once you start to see some of
that data and you're like wait no i was
up until 2am watching netflix and the
nights that i go to bed at seven or
eight or sorry i eat dinner at seven or
eight go to bed at 10 or 11. hey i
actually feel way better my data is
higher and able to then register and
quantify it this was better for me this
is a better behavior i want to feel
better i want to be more productive i
want to be on top of my interviews the
next day whatever it may be you can
check out the full podcast on
youtube.com samebrain or you can look up
same brain anywhere that you listen to
podcasts this ring is so small and light
that i hardly even notice that it's on
during the day or while i'm sleeping now
i know the apple watch does have sleep
tracking but i just really don't like
wearing something around my wrist when i
go to bed the aura rings main focus is
sleep so it is tracking your heart rate
hrv your body temperature and movements
all throughout the night to give you an
estimate of just how you slept every
morning i sink my ring and i can get all
of these in-depth metrics of how my
sleep was you can see on this particular
night i was awake for 45 minutes in rem
for one hour 42 minutes light sleep for
4 hours 10 minutes and deep sleep for 1
hour 18 minutes there is a movement
detection right here at the bottom so
around 2 30 a.m this is where my dog
woke me up and wanted out of the bedroom
so what did i do i woke up let him out
and fell back asleep so we have all of
this information but what can we do with
it how can we improve now this is what i
love so much because you can click into
things like my recovery index here it is
giving me an alert to pay attention this
recovery index measures how long it
takes for your resting heart rate to
stabilize during the night it gives you
a suggestion that alcohol a heavy meal
before bed can all have some negative
effects on your sleep and recovery and
uh you guess what yeah i ate a pretty
large meal last night before bed and i
knew like as i was eating this that it
was gonna play a factor in my sleep
quality once you start learning and
figure out how these small things can
affect your sleep you're able to adjust
and make the changes with bedtime
suggestions you'll be able to optimize
the amount of sleep that you'll need for
a full night recovery the next day i
have also used this as an excuse as to
why i can't go out it's like uh hi sorry
my ring just told me that i need to go
to sleep so i won't be able to make it
to that event like i can freaking send
my friends a screenshot like look see
proof i gotta go to bed bye you'll also
get some notifications of when it's time
to wind down so you can start preparing
yourself for bed and a lot of these
times i will be in the middle of working
or about to have dinner and this
notification pops up i'm like oh shoot
it's almost time to go to sleep um hi so
i'm in the middle of something if like
maybe you can just give me a few more
minutes so it's times like that where i
need to just kind of let go and realize
okay tonight might not be my best night
of sleep but i can try to plan for the
rest of the week to try to squeeze in
some makeup sleeps it does feel like it
sometimes becomes like this rubik's cube
type puzzle of how am i gonna make up
for the sleep that i failed to get last
night so after you've gathered a few
months of data the trend tab starts to
get very interesting to look at and i
wish that i would have had one of these
rings for years because that's so much
sleep data that i could have had but you
can see here that i started wearing this
in august and you can see that my sleep
score was very very low now me and my
sister were out working on a project
that required some crazy wake-up times
and very late nights but being able to
see this improvement month after month
is actually really cool my sister and i
were in hawaii and i was so nervous
because we were hiking and doing a ton
of outside activities that i was so
worried that like my brand new ring
would get scratched and i'm very happy
to report that it stayed in really great
condition even after some extensive
lightsaber battles and climbing up
mountains i do have the luxury of
working from home and there are times
that i am able to squeeze in a nap
during the day if i'm feeling really
exhausted this has automatic nap
detection it's really cool because after
i wake up from my nap it'll be able to
detect it it'll add on to your sleep and
your readiness score and it honestly
kind of feels like a real life video
game i'm trying to hack my day to
improve my energy levels we only get one
life so we need to make the best of it
and i just wish that i had started
focusing more on my sleep and healthy
living way earlier in life i am so happy
that now this has become a huge focus
for me just because i'm wearing this
ring though this isn't going to
magically make me be able to sleep
better we have to listen to our bodies
and actually take these suggestions and
then make the changes but what's great
though is when you actually find
something and you make that change for
the better you'll actually be able to
see the proof not only in the data but
how you're starting to feel this goes
back to my original question in the
beginning of this video which i actually
saw harpreet asked during an interview
once if there was a pill that you could
take to help you solve all of these
issues with your body would you and the
answer is such a simple one like we
don't need a pill we just need more
sleep now i thankfully don't have issues
falling asleep but for me it's making
the time to do so or the bad choices
that lead up to going to bed like i'm on
my phone i'm eating a huge meal before
bed or i'm working out like an hour
before it's time to go to sleep but for
others it's you can't shut your mind off
or you wake up multiple times during the
night and you're unable to fall back
asleep or you have kids a pet or a
partner that moves around too much there
are so many factors that lead into the
why we don't get enough sleep so what
are some things that we can do there are
so many sleep resources online so i
would suggest doing some research and
starting small trying to make some small
changes here and there and see what
works for you most importantly try to
eat or drink alcohol at least three
hours before bed eating large meals
right before you fall asleep can result
in your heart rate spiking throughout
the night and this won't allow you to
fully rest so i stopped drinking a few
years ago but as for alcohol it can
actually interrupt your sleep cycle in
the middle of the night because it'll
begin to metabolize in your body on a
typical night you'll go through about
four to six sleep cycles and not all are
the same length aura's sleep interface
makes it really simple to track these
cycles it uses awake rem light and deep
sleep to give you this visual
representation of your night waking up
in the middle of a cycle can also be
really detrimental to your day if your
body is naturally waking up before your
alarm just get up and get moving because
trying to squeeze in those extra few
minutes might actually have a reverse
effect so it's no secret that i am a
caffeine queen i love coffee i love
yerba mate about a year and a half ago i
started limiting myself to one coffee
and one yerba mate and it has to be
before 1 or 2 p.m so try to limit your
caffeine and your naps to earlier in the
day start setting an actual bedtime and
sticking to that schedule as much as
possible i love using the iphone bedtime
to calculate how much sleep i'll be able
to get and adjust accordingly if i can
i've found about seven hours or so
actually works best for me but i do like
to set it for about seven and a half or
eight since i usually do wake up before
my actual alarm this has taken me some
time to kind of train my body to be on
the schedule i like to wake up around 5
30 or 6 every day so for you guys just
start making small changes in your
routine and see what works there are
some sleep sounds and meditations built
into the aura app with more content
that'll be coming out later meditation
might not be for everyone but if you
haven't tried it i would definitely
recommend giving it a shot another huge
factor is your sleeping environment i
just recently got blackout curtains and
it is the best thing ever you might want
to try lighter bedding if you find
yourself overheating during the night
making small temperature adjustments
adding some calming white noise maybe
it's loud outside so you could try some
earplugs there are so many incredible
online sleep resources to get you guys
started on your sleep journey to better
sleep and to better health now aura ring
has honestly helped me so much and i've
already learned so much about my body
that i never even knew and i am honestly
so sad to admit this that until four
months ago i never knew that before your
period your body temperature
significantly decreases like what i'm
i'm how how old am i now like how did i
not know that i love being active and
having low energy is something that i've
always struggled with so pairing this
ring with better food choices with more
consistent workouts and trying to follow
an actual sleep schedule has been so
life-changing so i hope that if you guys
take away anything from this video is
how important it is to prioritize your
health over anything else because if you
guys can't be at your best for you how
will you be the best for anyone else
your work your family your friends i
think we've all felt that feeling of
complete burnout and just absolute
exhaustion and sometimes it's
unavoidable due to travel or work or
family or whatever it is what we do to
recover and move forward from that can
make all of the difference thank you
guys for watching this was really a
special video for me to make because
i've been doing a ton of sleep research
recently and i'm really excited to share
those with you if you guys would like to
get more information or purchase one of
your own you guys can check out
auraring.com ijustine and if you already
have one feel free to screenshot me
those sleep scores i would love to see
them and with that i'll see you guys in
the next video bye
[Music]
you